guys we're gonna answer some questions
now that came to us via Twitter it
always makes me a little bit nervous
because I did not pre-screen these we'll
just see what we have and go from there
let's start with Mike s Darnell why is
Sean McDermott not in the discussion for
coach of the year considering the
situation he came into and what he and
Brandon being have built in Buffalo
Chris I'll give you that one first well
you know I'm the president of Shawn
McDermott fan club so yeah I mean for me
he is you're the president of a lot of
things well they're just to what Raymond
Rogers and Odell Beckham jr. that's the
only one yes up to three okay
hey that's three I got coach's offense
you know I've got a few guys there all
right but either way huge fan of Shawn
McDermott he does deserve to be in that
conversation he's one of the best
coaches in football but you know it's a
year to where I think there's some other
guys that really stand out whether
that's Shanahan Tomlin Harbaugh Lafleur
so it's a strong year like I'm like
genuinely intrigued this year to see who
wins this award because I feel like
usually you like we have a tell this
time of the year who it's gonna be guys
I don't know you tell me who do you
think the leader in the clubhouse is for
coach of the year right now
well my leader in the clubhouse right
now would be Mike Tomlin and but that
but as I say about all these awards
every year it's a somebody asked me last
week so does that clinch the MVP for
Lamar Jackson no I mean it's a 17 week
award what happens if it was
such-and-such happens in the last two
weeks and Russell Wilson does this and
Lamar Jackson does that I don't know but
as of right now Lamar Jackson would be
my MVP choice as of right now it would
be Mike Tomlin for me but the last two
weeks of the season means something you
know if the Steelers drop a couple of
games here and don't play well down the
stretch that means something exactly the
same with if you know if the bills go to
New England on Saturday and wins and win
hey look he's in the discussion right
now along with Harbaugh and Shanahan
those four guys would be at the top of
my list right now so it's not over I
think he's got a shot yeah and I think I
think this is going to be a divide
year for coach of the year there isn't
one dominant guy who I think should get
it and I don't think we'll start to get
clarity guys until we see the playoff
tree the seedings in the two conferences
if the Saints are the 1 seed how do you
not consider Sean Payton considering you
went 5 and OH without Drew Brees
if the bills end up winning the AFC East
how do you not seriously consider Sean
McDermott at that point a lot to be
determined though over the final two
weeks of the season before we lock in
those playoff berths and John Harbaugh
needs consideration he's gonna have
number one tied up if they beat the
Browns this weekend and that
revolutionary offense and the fact that
he's shown in Greg Roman how does John
Harbaugh not get a lot of votes oh I
agree with you Peter I think a lot of
different guys are gonna get votes but
the clarity for the voter doesn't arrive
until we know exactly where all the
teams end up in that playoff tree all
right let's move on to James cam 17
predict the NFC East coaches for the
Cowboys the Giants and Washington in
2020 Peter King you get this one first
boy I'm glad you gave me some notice on
this one Mike okay all right I will
predict I will predict for the New York
Giants Mike McCarthy I will predict for
the Dallas Cowboys Lincoln Riley and I
will predict for Washington jeez I have
no idea
know whether let's just say for the sake
no I'm not going with her I just can't
believe that sorry
I'll give them Greg Roman even though I
think Roman is gonna have other choices
I think a dant Daniel Snyder is gonna
want to go with a quarterback whisperer
you want me answer that Mike or you want
to go answer if you're gonna give me I'm
gonna go Giants josh mcdaniels
I'm gonna go Urban Meyer Redskins okay I
think they need some sort of splash
thing and I have no idea or inkling of
what they want to do yet so I don't know
and then for the Dallas Cowboys I think
I'm gonna go Matt rule from Baylor I
just think he's gonna get a lot of
sniffs in the NFL it makes sense a
little to what you know Peter saying
with the Lincoln Riley thing Matt rules
right down the road as well they're from
the Dallas
and I think he's done a phenomenal job
got NFL head coach written all over him
all right I'm gonna go Ron Rivera with
the Giants because I would suspect that
Dave Kellerman has been working his butt
off over the last two weeks to try to
get ownership to keep get Ulm in' and
give Rivera a shot I'll agree with you
Chris on Urban Meyer to Washington
because I think it's Bruce Allen's Hail
Mary pass to try to keep his job and for
Dallas I'm going with two alternatives
Sean Payton's the first choice don't get
Sean Payton Mike Zimmer move on to the
next one let's just let that hang out
there and let's move on to the next one
at West Coast Baez after reading Simms
top quarterbacks of all time I'm worried
about him when was the last time he went
to the doctor Chris I don't know at West
Coast bias why don't you learn how to
spell my name correctly and then I know
that what's what's the problem with my
quarterback list that's what I want to
know I mean you know what what is it you
know okay yeah but people don't like
that I put Brees ten is that the problem
I mean yeah I don't I don't know what
else to say sorry Brees is awesome being
in the top ten of anything career-wise
is amazing this is not like a bad thing
but what do like people think like John
Elway and Dan Marino if they played with
Sean Payton wouldn't like have the same
stats I bet you they'd have more than
zero MVPs I bet you they'd have more
than one Superbowl so again that's just
where I come down on that I'm sorry
everybody I can't please everyone all
right
let's move on Terry Gensler 14 how much
stock do you put into what Carson Wentz
is doing and his abilities based on the
surrounding cast of characters he's had
on offense this year Peter the last six
quarters have shown me that the
Philadelphia Eagles faith in Carson
Wentz is well placed you know playing
with mostly backup guys and guys who
weren't even on your team a month or a
month and a half ago I give him a
tremendous amount of credit even though
he's beating lesser teams his last two
drives against the New York Giants were
big time drives in a game you needed to
save your season his end of the
game against Washington those were
big-time throws against Washington
particularly his high arcing throw to
win the game too great right so to me I
applaud the patience and and and also
the face the Doug Peterson has
consistently shown this year when Carson
Wentz has been exceedingly up and down
yeah I mean I think Carson Wentz has
opened up a lot of eyes the last two
weeks first of all this is what a
franchise quarterback does owe the
team's heard oh we're not playing good
on defense or offense don't worry guys
I'll just make drives happen when we
need it doesn't matter Oh nobody's open
doesn't matter I'll just stick it under
your chin no matter how good the
coverage is oh the pass protections on
that great oh I'll just stand there and
people be hitting me and trying to pull
me down as I throw lasers all over the
field
you know Carson Wentz I think I really
do I feel like public perception has
changed the last two weeks about them a
little bit because people realize the
supporting cast is so underwhelming
there and yeah it's it's not a great
teams he's playing but I think we're all
seeing the talent that guy has I mean
well you know this is a guy he's got MVP
capabilities we saw that already they
just need to get a weapon or two around
the guy and I think he's got superstar
written all over him yeah and Kris
something we've said in the
not-too-distant past if you take Carson
Wentz and put him on the Rams this year
yeah and you take Jared Goff and put him
on the Eagles yeah the Rams are in the
playoffs and the Eagles are four and
twelve I'm with you there Mike I totally
am and I know I know it's hard to play
that what-if game but I think you know
anybody who's watched football the last
two weeks is you know you see that
Carson Wentz is capable of doing special
special things on the football field I'm
not saying he's Patrick mahomes Lamar
Jackson but he's still got special
talents and certainly worthy of that
franchise quarterback label all right
let's squeeze in one more at Broncos fan
where do you see the Broncos next year
they have their quarterback at least for
next season tons of cap space and a high
draft pick Chris we'll start with you
what do you think they can do in 2020
well I think they're one of those teams
and say like watch out for in 2020 first
off let's remember this guy's right it's
Vic Fangio it's going to be a second
year
next year he's got guys still learning
this new system he doesn't have all the
guys he wants four three four they don't
have arguably their best defensive
player and Bradley Chubb I mean it's him
or von Miller
so think about him being back next year
and then you talk about drew Locke
Philip Lindsay Noah fan Courtland sudden
Tim Patrick DeSean Hamilton and that's
some young studs young firepower like I
think the Broncos have set themselves up
to very very much to be in the playoff
conversation next year and be one of
those teams look here's the thing with
the Denver Broncos the best thing that
has happened to them is the emergence of
drew Locke for this reason and this
reason only now there isn't pressure
yeah on John Elway and his right-hand
man in personnel Matt Russell to go out
and to search again for a quarterback
you're going with Drew Locke in 2020
that's your lot right now so let us
improve the rest of the team let's make
our offensive line
a good solid offensive line yeah let's
give the secondary some young help you
got Chris Harris jr. Kareem Jackson
they're getting older so you've got to
do something to to give that secondary
some youth and Chris you were absolutely
right right now one of the top five
young receivers in the NFL is Portland
Sutton he's got incredible hands he's
acrobatic he is a fantastic young
football player to me there's no reason
why the Denver Broncos are not a 10 win
team in 2020 and a wildcard playoff team
a couple of wins shy of Kansas City you
know when you think about it all these
years since Peyton Manning's retired
where they ricochet from one quarterback
to the next in the AFC West next year
the Chiefs have mahomes
the Broncos have Locke and the other two
teams who knows what they're going to do
at the most important position on the
field that instantly gives the Broncos
an advantage heading into 20
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports